- So we got the best safety
in the NFL, Jamal Adams.
And we got a little bit upset,
that you guys can't hit people this year.
- Can you feel it?
- Put your elbow up there
- Okay, sorry.
- [Laughing]
Do you feel that?
You wanna hit people more?
- Most definitely, man.
It's getting soft.
- It is. I'm a wussy quarterback
and I think it's getting soft.
- We're tired of it, so we brought
him to the Wrecking Club in New York
and we're gonna smash some crap.
You down?
- Let's do it.
♪♪♪
- For all of my haters...
- [Laughing]
That's incredible.
The ceiling came down.
- We're tired of
your constant winning
and your sustained excellence
and you get all the calls,
and we're just done with it!
I hate you so much!
- [Laughing]
- For those who said
I couldn't cover Gronk.
Damn.
- Holy crap.
- Wow.
- I felt like a lot of that
came out of you there.
- Yeah, a lot
of frustration, man.
Uh...damn it.
- Look at that.
- Yeah, he's gotta go
to the blue tent now.
- I'm sick of being accessible
all the time!
I'm sick of walkin' around
New York City
with everybody like this
and they don't even look
at anybody anymore.
- Bum-ba-duh-duh!
- New phone, who dis?
- This is to every person
in the Instagram comment section
with a big f--king mouth.
- [Laughing]
God, that feels so good.
- It does.
I get it.
Damn, that was a good one.
- They're doin' an hour-long
Phil Simms special.
What do you think about it?
- But we need to fix this TV.
I like it.
- [Laughing]
- That relieve any of the stress?
- Most definitely, man.
Felt damn good.
- See?
That's why people come on
"Simms & Lefkoe."
We're the Players' Show.
- It's true, it's true.
- We are here for you.
- [Smashing glass]
Ahh! Damn you!
- Tell you what, receivers
are in trouble
cuz now he's loosened up
and ready to go.
- Over with.